The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN OPPENHEIM: Hi.
As you recall, last
time we developed
the discrete-time
Fourier transform.
And one of the issues
that I alluded to,
although I didn't
say it explicitly,
is that the Fourier
transform doesn't
exist for all sequences.
In fact, as we'll see today,
one of the difficulties
is the issue of convergence.
That is, the Fourier
transform doesn't
converge for all sequences.
And to get around
this, we'll generalize
the notion of the Fourier
transform as we introduced it
last time to what's called the
Z-transform, the Z-transform
being the discrete time
counterpart of the Laplace
transform for
continuous time systems.
Well, let me begin by examining
just a little this issue
of convergence.
We have here the Fourier
transform relationship
as we developed it last time,
x of e to the j omega given
by the sum of x of 10 times
e to the minus j omega n.
And as we discussed the
Fourier transform last time,
we assumed that the
sum was convergent,
and-- or at least we didn't
particularly raise the issue
as to whether it is or isn't.
Well, we can look at the
magnitude of x, or equivalently
the magnitude of
this sum, and ask
under what conditions
this sum will converge.
That is, under what conditions
will this sum be finite.
Well, here we have the
magnitude of a sum of things
from what's called the
triangle inequality,
or you can just kind
of imagine that this
is true from common sense, is
that the magnitude of a sum
has to be less than or equal
to the sum of the magnitudes.
So the magnitude of this
sum has to be less than
or equal to the sum of
the magnitude of x of n e
to the minus j omega n.
The magnitude of a product is
the product of the magnitudes,
of course.
So this says that the magnitude
of the Fourier transform
has to be less than or equal to
the sum of the magnitude of x
of n times the magnitude of
the complex exponential, e
to the minus j omega n.
Well, this of course we
can't say a lot about.
This we can recognize as unity.
It's a complex exponential.
The magnitude of a complex
exponential is one.
So consequently, the magnitude
of the Fourier transform
is less than or equal to the
sum of the magnitudes of x
of n summed over minus
infinity-- n equals
minus infinity to plus infinity.
Well, that tells us then
that the Fourier transform
will converge, converge meaning
that the sum ends up finite,
if this converges.
That is, certainly if
this sum is finite,
then the magnitude of x of
e to the j omega is finite.
So we can say that x of e to the
j omega, the Fourier transform,
converges if the sum of
the magnitude of x of n
is less than infinity.
Well, this is a condition
that's commonly referred
to as absolutely summable.
The condition is that
the sequence x of n
be absolutely summable.
The way we've gone through
this, the statement
is that, if x of n is
absolutely summable,
then the Fourier
transform converges
under some sorts of conditions.
And depending on how you
interpret convergence,
this can be modified somewhat.
But basically--
and that, in fact,
is discussed in some
detail in the text.
But basically, the condition
for convergence of the Fourier
transform is that the sequence
whose Fourier transform we're
talking about be
absolutely summable.
Now, we've seen a sum
like this someplace else.
In fact, a couple
lectures ago, we
talked about stability
of discrete time systems.
And the statement
about stability
was that the unit sample
response of the system
be absolutely summable.
That is, or was, that, if
the unit sample response
is absolutely summable,
then the system is stable.
So one conclusion, which
you should tuck away for now
and we'll be bringing into
play later on in this lecture,
is that a stable system
implies that the system--
that the frequency response,
or the Fourier transform
of the unit sample
response, converges.
So this is convergence, then.
And we can look at a
couple of examples just
to see how this looks
in some specific cases.
Let's first of all take the
example of the sequence x of n
is 1/2 to the n u of n as an
exponential sequence which
is zero for n less than zero
because of the unit step.
It's exponentially decaying
for n greater than zero.
If we sum the
magnitude of x of n
from minus infinity
to plus infinity,
we get that the magnitude, the
sum of the magnitude of x of n
is equal to two.
Well, this is
something, a type of sum
that hopefully you're
familiar with carrying out.
In any case, what we're
summing here is the series
1, 1/2, 1/4, 1/8, et cetera.
That sums to two.
So we can say that, for
this sequence, certainly,
the Fourier transform converges.
It's a perfectly
well-behaved sequence.
A Fourier transform
converges, we
can compute the Fourier
transform, et cetera.
Well, another sequence we can
try is the sequence x of n
equals 2 to the n
times a unit step.
Well, if we just
think about the values
that we have, at n equals
zero we have 1, at n equals 1,
we have 2, at n equals 2,
we have 4, at n equals 3,
we have 8.
And obviously, then, the
sum of the absolute values
of x of n for that
particular sequence diverges.
That is, the sum is infinite.
So here's an example of a
sequence for which the Fourier
transform doesn't converge.
In other words, the Fourier
transform for this sequence
doesn't exist.
And you can imagine
the generalization here
that, if we talk
about a sequence which
decays exponentially--
by the way,
in either direction, negative
n or positive n-- then
the Fourier
transform will exist,
whereas if it's an
exponential sequence that
grows exponentially, then
the Fourier transform is not
going to exist, or is
not going to converge.
Well, what do we do about that?
There is a way around
it by essentially using
the artifice of
multiplying a sequence that
doesn't converge, or say
that grows exponentially
by a decaying
exponential, and making
the decay on the exponential
fast enough so that the product
has a Fourier transform.
That is, we can talk about
the Fourier transform
in general, not of
x of n, but of x
of n multiplied by a sequence
r to the minus n, for which we
pick r so that the
product of these two
is absolutely summable.
And since we've introduced
another parameter r, then
the Fourier transform of x
of n times r to the minus n,
we don't want to call
x of e to the j omega.
Let's for now think of it as
x of r times e to the j omega,
the r denoting the
complex exponential
that we're multiplying by.
And then, of course,
for some values of r,
this sum is going to converge.
For other values of r, this
sum is not going to converge.
For example, if we
look at our example
two here, if I multiply
this sequence by a decaying
exponential that
decays fast enough so
that the product decays--
and what do I have
to multiply it by?
I have to multiply it by
something that decays faster
than 1/2 to the n.
So if I stick in here an
r that is greater than 2--
2 because there's a minus
sign here, r to the minus n--
then I'll end up with,
for this sequence,
with a sum here that converges.
So for this example, if r--
any choice of r greater
than two, this sum
is going to converge.
And I can talk about x
of r of e to the j omega.
So that's the idea.
The idea is to multiply
by an exponential that
decays fast enough
or doesn't grow
so fast that the product x
of n times r to the minus n
converges.
Well, we can rewrite this
a little differently.
We can combine the r to the
minus n and the e to the minus
j omega n.
And what results is
the sum, minus infinity
to plus infinity,
of x of n times
re to the j omega
to the minus n,
just simply combining
these two terms together.
And it's convenient to think of
this as a new complex variable,
magnitude r and angle
omega, which we'll denote
by z, z as in the Z-transform.
The Z-transform.
So, this essentially leads us to
the notion of the Z-transform,
where the Z-transform
of a sequence x of n
is defined as x of z is equal
to the sum of x of n times z
to the minus n, where z is equal
to r times e to the j omega.
In other words, x of z is
just simply the x sub r of e
to the j omega that we
finished talking about.
Well, how is the Z-transform
related to the Fourier
transform if the Fourier
transform exists?
Obviously, from what we
just finished saying,
the Z-transform is the Fourier
transform for this weighting
factor r equal to unity.
That is, x of e to the j omega
is equal to x of z where?
Well, for z equal to
e to the j omega--
or another way of saying that
is for the magnitude of z
equal to unity.
With z equal to e to the j
omega, the magnitude of z
obviously is equal to unity.
So we have now the Z-transform.
It's a function of
a complex variable
z, which has a magnitude
r and an angle omega.
And it's just simply
a generalization
of the Fourier transform.
It, in fact, is
equal to the Fourier
transform for the
magnitude of z equal to 1.
And it, in effect, corresponds
to the Fourier transform
of the sequence multiplied
by an exponential sequence r
to the minus n.
When does the
Z-transform converge?
Well, the Z-transform converges
when this x sub r of e
to the j omega that we were
talking about converges.
And that converges when the
sequence x of n r to the minus
n is absolutely summable.
So the Z-transform
converges if the sum
of x of n times r to
the minus n is finite.
And for some values of r,
given a certain sequence,
for some values of r the
Z-transform will converge,
Z-transform won't converge.
Well let's look at an example.
And it's an example,
I guess, that you're
seeing fairly frequently.
In fact, it'll keep cropping
up in a variety of ways.
It's kind of a simple
one, and nice to use.
That is the sequence--
our old friend again--
x of n is 1/2 to
the n times u of n.
Well, the Z-transform of x of
n, x of z is the sum of x of n
z to the minus n.
Since this is multiplied
by a unit step,
the limits on the sum are
from zero to infinity.
So this is the sum from zero
to infinity of 1/2 to the n z
to the minus n.
And that's equal to the sum from
n equals 0 to infinity of 1/2
times z to the minus 1-- just
combining these together--
to the n.
Now, let me point
out, incidentally--
and I think that by
now you've seen this--
this is a kind of sum,
this geometric series
is a kind of sum that comes up
over and over and over again
in dealing with sequences.
And it's the kind of summation
that you should carry around
in your hip pocket.
That is, you should keep
in mind, because it keeps
coming up like
standard integrals do
in the continuous time
case, that the sum from 0
to infinity of a to the n--
a has to be less than 1 for
convergence-- of a to the n
is equal to 1 over 1 minus a.
Just store that away.
Anyway, summing this, then,
we end up with 1 over 1
minus this thing.
So the Z-transform is 1
over 1 minus 1/2 times z
to the minus 1, which we
can leave in this form.
And sometimes, we will.
Or, we can multiply
numerator and denominator
by z, in which case we have
z divided by z minus 1/2.
Well, when does this converge?
It converges when the magnitude
of 1/2 times z to the minus 1
raised to the n is finite.
And that requires
that this thing
that we're taking the
absolute magnitude of be--
raised to the n--
be less than unity,
or that implies
that z, the magnitude of z,
must be greater than 1/2.
The magnitude of z must
be greater than 1/2,
or the magnitude of z
minus z to the minus 1
must be less than two.
Magnitude z to the
minus 1 less than two,
or the magnitude of
z greater than 1/2.
And under those conditions,
the Z-transform will converge.
Now, for this example, does
the Fourier transform exist?
Does the Fourier
transform converge?
How do we answer that?
Well, the Fourier
transform converges
if the convergence
of the Z-transform
includes the magnitude
of z equal to 1.
Does it?
Sure it does.
The magnitude of z must
be greater than 1/2
for convergence of
the Z-transform.
That includes the
magnitude of z equal to 1.
Therefore, for this sequence,
the Fourier transform
converges.
We had already decided
that before, of course.
That is obviously a
better turnout that way
this time also.
But an important notion,
then, is interpreting
the existence of the
Fourier transform
in terms of the region of
convergence of the Z-transform.
This then defines the
region of convergence,
the set of values of z for
which the Z-transform converges.
Another interesting
observation about this example
is that we ended up
with a Z-transform that
is a ratio of polynomials.
In this case, z to the minus
1 or, If we rewrite it,
a ratio of polynomials in z.
And that's an
important observation.
In fact, it is a
consequence of the fact
that we're talking
about the Z-transform
of an exponential sequence.
Any exponential sequence will
have a Z-transform that's
a ratio of polynomials in z.
Furthermore, any sequence
that's a sum of exponentials
will have a Z-transform that's
a ratio of polynomials in z,
since the Z-transform of a sum
is the sum of the Z-transforms,
and the sum of a
ratio of polynomials
is a ratio of
polynomials and all that.
But basically, the
point to remember
is that sums of
exponentials as sequences
result in Z-transforms that
are ratios of polynomials in z,
or in z to the minus 1.
Well, for those class of
sequences, which, in fact, are
most of the
sequences we're going
to be talking about
in these lectures,
it's convenient to look at
the Z-transform graphically,
in terms of a plot
in the z-plane.
So I've indicated
here the z-plane.
This is the real
part of z, this axis.
This axis is the
imaginary part of z.
And I've drawn a
circle, which I've
called the unit circle, which
is convenient to focus on.
It's the circle in the z-plane
for which the magnitude of z
is equal to 1.
What's important about the
magnitude of z equal to 1?
Well, it's on that
circle, when we
look at the Z-transform
on that circle,
that we see the
Fourier transform.
So it's often convenient
to make reference
to the unit circle in
the z-plane corresponding
to the place in the z-plane
where the Z-transform is
equal to the Fourier transform.
When we have a Z-transform that
is a ratio of polynomials in z,
it's convenient to
represent it in terms
of the roots of the
numerator polynomial
and the roots of the
denominator polynomial.
The roots of the
numerator polynomial
we'll refer to as the
zeros of the Z-transform.
They're those values of z
for which the Z-transform
is going to be zero.
And the roots of the
denominator polynomial
we'll refer to as the
poles of the Z-transform.
Those are the
values of z at which
the Z-transform blows up,
just like poles and zeros
of the Laplace transform in
the continuous time case.
We'll denote in the z-plane
roots, the zeros, by a circle,
and we'll denote the
poles by a cross.
So we have, for that particular
example, a zero at the origin,
since the numerator
polynomial was simply z,
and we have a pole
at z equal to 1/2.
Well, what else do we know
about this Z-transform?
We know that the
Z-transform doesn't
exist for all values of z.
In particular,
for convergence we
require that the magnitude
of z is greater than 1/2.
So I've indicated that
region in the z-plane,
with these slanted lines,
the region of convergence
for this particular example
are those values of z that
lie outside the circle that's
bounded by the pole at z
equal to 1/2.
And we'll see that that is,
in fact, the way regions
of convergences tend to go.
They'll tend to be
outside and inside poles.
So the important
aspects of this picture,
there are the zeroes
and the poles,
there's the unit circle
where the Z-transform is
equal to the Fourier
transform, and there's
the region of convergence, which
tells us where in the z-plane
the Z-transform makes sense.
All right.
Let's try another example.
Let's take the example of
x of n equal to minus 1/2
to the n u of minus n minus 1.
Now, you saw that sequence
a couple of lectures ago.
It's a sequence that
is like 1/2 to the n,
but not for positive
values of n,
but for negative values of n.
In other words, it's zero
for positive values of n,
and it does something
exponentially
for negative values of n.
If you evaluate the
Z-transform sum--
and I'll leave it
to you to do this--
then we end up with x
of z, the Z-transform,
is 1 over 1 minus
1/2 z to the minus 1,
just like we saw before.
In fact, that's exactly
the same expression
as a ratio of polynomials
that we saw before,
which, of course,
we can rewrite,
as we did before, as z
divided by z minus 1/2.
All right.
Do you think that the Fourier
transform of this sequence
exists?
Well, it's 1/2 to
the n, which dies out
for negative n-- for positive n.
But for negative n,
that's a sequence
that grows exponentially.
So in fact, if you examine
convergence of this,
this sequence is not
absolutely summable.
The Fourier transform
does not exist.
What's the region of
convergence of the Z-transform?
Well, to decide that, we need to
look at the sum of 1/2 times e
to the minus 1 to the n, and ask
for what values of z this sum
is less than infinity.
In other words, for what
values of z that sum converges.
And to do that, if this was a
sum over positive values of n,
then we would want the magnitude
of this to be less than 1.
Since we're looking at this
for negative values of n,
we want the magnitude of
this to be greater than 1.
And the conclusion is--
and if you don't
see this right away,
you can just fiddle with it
on the back of an envelope--
that this converges provided
that the magnitude of z
is less than 1/2.
So we can look at this
example in the z-plane,
just as we looked at
the previous example
in the z-plane.
We first of all have
poles and zeroes.
We have-- well, where
do we have a zero?
We have a zero at z equals 0.
So that's here.
We have a pole at
z equal to 1/2.
And that's here.
Just like in the previous
example, the zero and the pole
fall in exactly the same place.
What's the region
of convergence?
Well, the region of convergence
is for the magnitude
of z less than 1/2.
And now, in this case,
that's inside this circle,
rather than in
the previous case,
where it was
outside that circle.
So the region of convergence
now is the region
that is inside the circle,
which is bounded by that pole.
All right.
This raises an important point.
Here we had an example where
we got a Z-transform ratio
of polynomials.
The previous example, we
got exactly the same ratio
of polynomials.
How did these two
examples differ
in terms of the Z-transform?
They differed in terms of
the region of convergence
that we associate
with the Z-transform.
The other case, the
region of convergence
was outside this circle.
In this case, the
region of convergence
is inside this circle.
The ratio of polynomials
for the Z-transforms
is the same in both cases.
It's the region of
convergence that's different.
So an important
point to keep in mind
is that the Z-transform
is not specified just
by the function of z,
it's also specified--
it has to have attached to it
a little tag that tells you
for what values of z
it's legitimate to look
at that expression.
So it's specified by the
ratio of polynomials,
and also by the region of
convergence of the Z-transform.
So here, for example, that's
the ratio of polynomials,
and that's the Z-transform.
That's the ratio of
polynomials, and that's
the region of convergence.
And the two together
are the Z-transform.
Now, it often happens that
the region of convergence
of the Z-transform is specified
in a somewhat indirect way,
by saying something about the
sequence that basically implies
what the region of
convergence has to be.
And we can lead
into that by stating
what some of the properties are
that the region of convergence
has.
And I'll always be talking
now about sequences
that are sums of
exponentials, or Z-transforms
that are ratios of polynomials,
and consequently that
can be described by poles
and zeroes in the z-plane.
OK, well, I have here the
first thing you can say.
Actually, there's
a 0 thing you can
say that follows fairly
straightforwardly, and that is,
obviously, there
can't be any poles
in the region of convergence
because, at a pole
of the Z-transform, that's
where the Z-transform blows up.
And we know that the
region of convergence
is where the
Z-transform converges.
So obviously, there are no poles
in the region of convergence.
However, we can make
another statement,
which is justified in
some detail in the text,
that the region of
convergence will always
be bounded by either
poles or zero or infinity.
For example, in this example
that we worked out here,
the region of convergence
goes to zero--
I mean, it includes zero--
and it's bounded at the outside,
in this particular case,
by a pole.
In the example that
we had previously,
if we look at this example,
the region of convergence
is bounded on the
inside by a pole,
and it's bounded on the
outside by infinity.
And that's a statement
that we can generally make.
I won't try to justify
that right now,
but the region of convergence
is bounded by poles,
and in fact is bounded
by a circle that
goes through a pole.
All right.
That's one statement
we can make.
Now some other statements
that we can make,
which are all
developed in the text.
That is, the proof of
them is worked out.
First of all, let's consider
finite length sequences.
A finite length
sequence, sequenced at 0,
except for a finite
number of values of n,
has a region of convergence that
is the entire z-plane, perhaps
with the exception
of the point z
equals 0, or perhaps with
the exception of the point z
equals infinity.
And that follows in a
pretty straightforward way,
basically because the sum, in
examining absolute convergence,
the sum just includes
finite limits.
So as long as each of the
sequence values is finite,
the sum has to be finite.
A little more involved, we
have right-sided sequences.
What I mean by a
right-sided sequence
is a sequence which is 0 for
n less than some value of n.
And then goes on up to
n equals plus infinity.
And what you can say about
right-sided sequences,
as it turns out, is that
the region of convergence
is outside some value, which
I've denoted by r sub x minus,
and goes to infinity.
It may include infinity or
it may not include infinity,
but it goes at least
up to infinity.
So it begins at
some finite value
in the z-plane, bounded
by some circle with radius
r sub x minus, and
goes up to infinity.
Well, look, if we had
a right-sided sequence,
how are you going to find
what r sub x minus is?
Just by looking at
the pole-zero pattern,
because we know that the
region of convergence
is bounded by poles.
We know also that the
region of convergence
can't have any poles,
so r sub x minus
has to be the circle that goes
through the outermost pole
in the z-plane.
So if we have a
right-sided sequence, that
implies a region
of convergence, it
implies that the
region of convergence
is outside the outermost
pole in the z-plane.
We can talk also about
left-sided sequences.
Left-sided sequences
are ones for which
the sequence is zero for n
greater than some value n1.
One And here, the region of
convergence begins at zero--
may or may not include zero,
depending on some issues about
the left-sided sequence, but
at least goes up to zero--
and then goes out to
some value r sub x plus.
How do we find r sub x plus?
We do it the same way.
That is, we know that
the region of convergence
is bounded by poles and
doesn't contain any poles,
so this must be a circle
whose radius is equal--
who's a circle that goes
through the innermost pole,
other than the one at z
equals 0 in the z plane.
So if I have a
left-sided sequence,
if I know it's a
then by looking at
the pole-zero pattern
I can immediately infer what
the region of convergence is.
Finally, we have two-sided
sequences, sequences
that go on to minus infinity and
they go on the plus infinity.
In that case, the
region of convergence
lies between two circles,
which go through two poles.
And obviously, again, they
have to be two poles that
are adjacent in the z-plane.
In other words, again, to
avoid having poles that
are inside the region
of convergence.
And out of all
this, incidentally,
if I tell you that I
have a sequence whose
Fourier transform exists,
and I don't tell you
anything else
about the sequence,
can you infer what the
region of convergence is?
Well, sure you can,
because you know
that the region of convergence
includes the unit circle.
And then where it's got to go
from there is to the first pole
that you run into heading
toward the origin,
and to the first pole that
you run into heading out
toward infinity.
So in fact, if I tell you that
the sequence is absolutely
summable, or that the Fourier
transform exists, that also,
in effect, lets you
construct the region
of convergence in the z-plane.
Well, let's just cement
this with an example.
Let's say that I have
a Z-transform which
has a pole-zero pattern that has
a pole at z equal a and a pole
at z equal b.
So this is a, and this is b.
And let's consider what turn
out to be the only three
possible choices for the
region of convergence, given
this pole-zero pattern.
No zeroes, to make
the example easy.
Well first of all,
let's suppose that we
picked the region of
convergence to be less than a.
So the region of convergence
for this first case
is inside a circle
bounded by that pole.
Well, let's see.
Let's answer the
easy question first.
Does the Fourier
transform exist?
To answer that, we
ask, is the unit circle
inside the region
of convergence?
Well, it's not if the
region of convergence
is inside that pole.
So for this case, the Fourier
transform doesn't exist.
That is, it doesn't converge.
How about which sided?
Left-sided,
right-sided, two-sided?
Well, we can answer
that, again, because we
know, from what we
said previously,
that a left-sided sequence has
a region of convergence that
starts at zero and goes out
to some value r sub x plus.
Well, that's the
region of convergence
that we're talking about here.
So this particular
example is a sequence
for a sequence
that's left-sided.
How about the region of
convergence between a and b?
Think of two circles
with radii a and b.
And now the region of
convergence is between them.
Does that include
the unit circle?
Yeah, it includes
the unit circle.
So for that case, the
Fourier transform exists.
Is it left-sided,
right-sided, or two-sided?
Well, it's two-sided, because
the region of convergence
doesn't make it to zero, and
it doesn't make it to infinity.
So this is a two-sided sequence.
The final example,
or the final choice
for the region of convergence,
the magnitude of z
greater than b.
Does the Fourier
transform exist?
No, because the
region of convergence
is outside this pole.
It doesn't include
the unit circle,
so the Fourier
transform doesn't exist.
Well, we can figure
out which sided
it is, either by using what
we know, or using quizmanship.
Here, we had left,
here we had two-sided,
so obviously it's right-sided.
In fact, it is right-sided,
because the region
of convergence starts at
some value r sub x minus,
and goes out to infinity.
So this case, then, is
a right-sided sequence.
This stresses, again,
the point that,
if I just specify the
pole-zero pattern, that
doesn't specify the Z-transform
or the sequence uniquely.
Now, one of the properties
of the Z-transform,
which follows essentially
directly from the fact that
the Z-transform is interpretable
in terms of the Fourier
transform-- or this could
be developed more formally,
and we won't do that here--
is the convolution property.
Namely, if y of n
is the convolution
of x of n with h of n, then
the Z-transform of y of n
is equal to the product of
the Z-transform of x of n
and the Z-transform of h of n.
That is, z transformation,
or the Z-transform, maps
convolution into multiplication,
just like the Fourier transform
did.
And that's not surprising.
We typically refer to
h of z, the Z-transform
of the unit sample
response of the system,
as the system function.
Well, on the basis of the
discussion that we just
finished, there are
some things that we
can say about the system
function and the unit sample
response and regions of
convergence, et cetera.
First of all, suppose that we're
talking about a stable system.
Stable system, the
unit sample response
is absolutely summable.
What does that imply
about the Z-transform?
Well, it implies
that the Z-transform,
the region of convergence
of the Z-transform
includes the unit circle.
That is, it implies the
Fourier transform exists,
or, equivalently, that
the Z-transform region
of convergence includes
the unit circle.
So this is a statement
that we can make.
Suppose that we were talking
about a stable system.
Sorry, suppose that we were
talking about a causal system.
If the system is causal,
well, what does causal mean?
It means that the
unit sample response
is zero for n less than zero.
In particular, the unit sample
response is right-sided.
If it's right-sided, then
the region of convergence
must be outside
the outermost pole,
because that's what we
said about what happens
with a right-sided sequence.
The region of convergence has to
be outside the outermost pole.
So you can get the
notion, then, that when
we talk about the Z-transform
of a system, in essence
we can imply the
region of convergence
by making some statements
about stability or causality.
All right.
Let's try this
out on an example.
Let's take an example
which, in fact,
we've talked about in some
lectures-- in a lecture
previously.
Let's take the example
of a system that
is represented by a linear
constant coefficient difference
equation, y of n minus 1/2,
y of n minus 1 equals x of n.
To get the system function for
this, we'll take a shortcut.
And in particular,
we'll use a property
that we haven't derived,
at least not yet,
but in fact you'll be
deriving in the study guide.
Notice how I put everything
off to the study guide.
When we get the
study guide, I'll
tell you we did it in lecture.
Well, the property is that
if the Z-transform of y of n
is y of z, then the
Z-transform of y of n plus n0
is z to the n0 times y and z.
So if we take the Z-transform
of this difference equation, we
have, then, y of z, the
Z-transform of that minus 1/2
z to the minus 1, since
we have y of n minus 1, z
to the minus 1 y of z is
equal to the Z-transform
of the right side of the
equation, which is x of z.
Well, the system function
is equal to y of z
divided by x of z.
And so we can simply solve
this equation for y of z
over x of z.
And what we get is 1
over 1 minus 1/2 times z
to the minus 1.
So that's the system
function for that system.
Well, what's the
region of convergence?
We don't know what the
region of convergence is.
In fact, we're
going to have to--
in fact, there might
be several choices
for the region of convergence.
But that's not too
surprising, because remember
when we talked
about this equation
a couple of lectures ago and
we showed that, in fact, there
is more than one choice
for the unit sample
response of this system.
And that is related to the fact
that all we got out of here
so far was the ratio of
polynomials that h of z is,
and not what the region
of convergence is.
All right, so this
ratio of polynomials
is 1 over 1 minus 1/2
times z to the minus 1.
We've been staring at
that ratio of polynomials
through a couple of
previous examples.
It has a zero at z equals 0,
and a pole at z equals 1/2.
So let's take a look
at that in the z-plane.
We have then the z-plane
here, the unit circle.
We have, for the example we're
talking about, a zero there,
and a pole there.
And what's the region
of convergence?
Well, it seems like we can
take the region of convergence
to be whatever we want to
consistent with what regions
of convergences tend to do.
So let's say, for example,
that the region of convergence
was outside that pole.
So let's take a region
of convergence first that
looks like that.
Well, for that case, if that's
the region of convergence,
there are some things that we
could say about the system.
For example, is
the system stable?
Is the system stable if
the unit sample response
has a Fourier transform?
And it has that if the
region of convergence
includes the unit circle,
which it does here.
So this particular
system is stable.
And is it causal?
Well, what we want to examine
for that region of convergence
is does it imply a
right-sided sequence.
Well, it does, because
the region of convergence
is outside this pole.
So in fact, for this example,
the system is also causal.
And in fact, look, we know
what the unit sample response
is because we've been working
with that example previously.
The unit sample response
here, in fact, is h of n
is 1/2 to the n
times a unit step.
But that's not the only choice
for the region of convergence.
We could, alternatively,
pick a region of convergence
which is inside that pole.
That is-- let's
look at this again.
Zero at the origin, a pole
at equals z equals 1/2.
But now let's take the
region of convergence
to be inside that pole.
If it's inside that
pole, then, first of all,
is the system stable?
No, it's not stable, because
the region of convergence
didn't include the unit circle.
So it's not stable.
And furthermore,
it's not causal.
In fact, it's just the reverse.
It's anti-causal.
It's not causal.
And in fact, we know,
again, what the unit sample
response is for that case
because we worked it out
previously, namely h of n is
equal to minus 1/2 to the n,
but for n negative,
not for n positive.
That is, multiplied by
u of minus n minus 1.
And this, by the way,
if you refer back
several lectures ago, is
consistent with the two
solutions that we got for a
linear constant coefficient
difference equation.
And now you can see
that, for example,
if I specified the
difference equation,
and I said that, in addition,
what we're talking about
is, say, a stable
system, then you
could construct the region
of convergence by saying,
all right, the unit
circle has to be
in the region of
convergence, and now I'll
take the region of convergence
to go in toward a pole
and out toward a pole.
Or if I said, the
system was causal,
then you could construct
the region of convergence.
So sometimes, in stating a
linear constant coefficient
difference equation, we'll
basically [AUDIO OUT]
convergence by making
an additional statement
about the system.
For [AUDIO OUT]
system is causal,
or the system is stable,
or both if it can be both.
[AUDIO OUT] So this
is the Z-transform.
Just to summarize
the key points first,
the Z-transform was
introduced to get around
the convergence problem
with the Fourier transform.
The Z-transform of sequences
that are exponentials
are ratios of polynomials.
That is, they can be described
in terms of poles and zeros.
But the Z-transform
is not specified just
by the ratio of polynomials.
You also need to know what
the region of convergence
is of the Z-transform
so that, in fact,
for several different
sequences, you
can end up with the same
ratio of polynomials,
but of course you'll
get different regions
of convergence.
Finally, the region
of convergence
includes the unit circle.
That tells us that the
Fourier transform converges.
And also, we're able
to make statements
about a region of
convergence as it
relates to right-sided,
left-sided, and two-sided
sequences.
Next time, we'll continue the
discussion of the Z-transform,
and in particular develop
the inverse Z-transform.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]